[Music]
good morning when OCS what's going on
today in the mouth I got the line you
really wanted to talk about this hell
it's because so yesterday I got my
Invisalign trays and I know what you
guys are gonna say and thank you so much
but yes I know it seems as if my teeth
are perfect but they're not they've
actually been shifting a lot because
they broke my retainer many years ago I
need a stop the shifting in its tracks
because getting worse
after this whole process with the
Invisalign stuff I want to get permanent
retainers and just never think about it
again
cuz I got braces when I was 21 years old
13 adults and then after braces and then
the retainer broke and then I ended up
doing what it was like in in the mail
the liner things I did that right before
we got married and it did work but it
just shifted my teeth a little weirdly
and it was just it wasn't perfect so
anyway bottom line Isaac got braces so I
was like hey I'm gonna get a liners to
it finally fixed issue because this
front tooth hero and I take photos I
could see this like it creating a shadow
with this too it's back here so it's
really annoying to me and I want to fix
it because I had to wear it anyway we're
hurting - JK news what I was gonna say
are you gonna wear for JK news you never
listen I'm shaking news I know because
I'm about to take them off to drink some
of my Starbucks I just got and eat
oatmeal I just ordered knowing myself
and I think I'm getting to know myself
pretty well these days I'm gonna forget
to put it back in but if I don't forget
and I do put the back in maybe I'll put
them on for like a couple articles and
see how
goes but I already know it's gonna annoy
me and I'm probably gonna take them out
but it's just one day out of the week
something that I'm not really we're not
filming JK party right now it's just
taking these that I have to worry about
it's only a couple hours one day a week
not gonna be that bad they have news now
get our morning ritual this is a jakey
news ritual which is a stuff in my
Starbucks yeah you got oatmeal yeah
accidentally ordered
yeah you didn't want to know meal today
you better bagel
I want a bagel so today I am gonna be
wearing my aligners for the first time
and also ahead for the first time I've
never worn a hat for Jake emus and and
that's not a big deal there's just that
kind of they're kind of like a tiny
little thing to point out of my day it's
like Oh wearing a head it's because for
the last this entire week guys be so
proud of me for this entire week today's
Thursday right since Monday Monday
Tuesday Wednesday three days in a row I
have been working out and because of
that I didn't wash my hair yesterday
which I know is kind of gross without
sweaty but at least my body's clean but
the reason why I'm wearing the hat is
because I didn't wash my hair it's all
like crazy it's crazy but the reason why
I didn't want to wash my hair is because
I can't wash my hair too much too often
because then it ends up affecting my
scalp and then I end up getting really
dry scalp and it also ends up washing
you wash away the natural oils from your
hair so it's not even recommended that
you've washed your head every single day
or even your body actually because then
you have natural oils on your body but
if you're sweaty you should probably
wash
it's just that yesterday I was too
stressed out trying to focus on JK news
that I was like listen I can't do my
whole hair ritual in the shower which is
to like read I ate and stuff so I'm like
I'm just gonna put a hat on and just
deal with it so but at least I get to
rep barbell brigade
I like that little curls in the
background you know it's so cute it's
such a perfect little girl you know if I
went bald and grow out my hair right now
I would probably have all this curly
hair like this - what kind of hair I
don't know it's a baby but oh you know
your baby photos you had - curly hair
yeah and this came out because Lindsay
was shaving the bottom portion of my of
my head when I had shorter hair because
this hair down here it was creating like
a like a Calot kind of thing which mean
my hair like go out like this it was
just really unlike but anyway like this
is like brand-new not dyed or process at
all hair and this is how it comes out
like all nice and curly but we got
because I do process my hair and stuff
it's not curly but I like this curl it's
some cute as anyone else a baby your
next hairstyle should be curly hair I've
been wanting to get a perm for such a
long time with that my hair girls
they're like don't do it it's gonna ruin
your hair it's gonna damage it horse
than bleaching it my my hair is already
pretty damaged because of the bleaching
so you know are you planning on
resetting your hair they're growing it
out and then jumping off the damaged
parts and then curling it permian yeah
you know what I think I might do that
it's just that take such a long time but
right now we're gonna be 10 years from
now what but right now I'm already
growing out all the bleach stuff outside
the blue it's like getting lower in
Laura cuz I haven't gone back to retie
it so I'm kind of thinking
growing it all out and letting the blue
just come out then I'll burn my hair I
didn't wanted a permit for such a long
time
look we're enjoy here oh yay same time
to the office mm-hmm we got I really
want my hair that's a plan
I'm bored you to it that's actually my
natural hair I want to see what I look
naturally you decided to take out your
name or anything called Invisalign
visit Lee yes I know I can talk and I
understand you oh come on but look how
cool the Invisalign retainer thingies
are cuz you know the other ones I have
there it's like really fat and bulky and
ugly tricks fits in my purse really
things like that Google home Google home
yeah we're like a hockey puck I already
feel my teeth shifting like they're
really sensitive c'mon yesterday
put them on and then now gonna have to
eat they feel really sore but I don't
even mind the soreness that much because
it tells me that something's working and
my teeth are moving it's so much cool
it's just the same way how now I don't
really get mad at the soreness like the
body soreness from working out because
then that just tells me like I did
something it actually worked like
something is happening and all my
efforts have not gone to waste because
my body is sore from it that's how I saw
that there's progress that's a healthy
relationship with pain lunchtime after
lunchtime my desserts this is something
Steve brought to uh drinking news
technically gave it to Bart I gave it to
the crew wow you even know them you
aren't you landed on Bart's tip art is
the most interesting always true thank
you got this chicken we're good say it
tastes like medicine which I agree I
know that something does taste that good
and they're healthy that goes through
our meat is I'm a goat no just kind of
eat anything TIFF yes
avoir adios sayonara yep I'm out of here
so does her first no it's not first
there's been an all-male cast before so
Steve's taking over yeah mom are you
ready son
yeah but guys guys get to take over now
alright and this is when I get the most
scared episodes all turn out really
terrible bad I am there's a retro bro oh
we got this no we do I know you a lot of
responsibility guys I mean I don't know
just kidding you're just like 18 videos
worth right what is it you said you were
gonna study during lunch and I have not
seen you open oh no no no I said I'm
gonna study for the first three during
lunch yeah I don't want to get them all
in my head that's where I think I heard
them all yesterday but as far as
refreshing
I don't refresh on the day oh that's so
unprofessional yes you do I seem to do
it no I refresh because that means I
didn't study that's right and it gets it
done 52 weeks out of the year wouldn't -
holidays which is so maybe like 45 weeks
out of the year so yeah I go - this is a
great ship with holes in the wall shape
holes in the wall film for our channel
around the rest of the guy at least I'm
not David yeah that's freaking David I
remember one time I was about to vlog
home like David please try not to cuss
and he goes don't you just causing your
fella how you sent your door.you and
host you're welcome thank you okay well
I'm gonna go home cuz isaac is such a
big kid alright it's a stay home alone
on his last day of summer which is not
that big of a deal because he wakes up
late anyway and inside time I get there
it's it's fine hey it's gonna be fine
well security system at home so don't
worry I Isaac safe he's okay alright
I'll see you guys I'm fine don't worry
we got it I love you hi baby
I know that was it let me pause this
you're watching Spongebob and it's the
pizza one krabby patty pizza is the
pizza for you and me so would you do
while we were gone I was just watching
Spongebob eat some ramen spicy ramen
actually good spicy ramen yeah
Hey look at you big kid making your own
ramen you're playing on the Chromebook
yeah do you think I was playing a Mario
game really that doesn't look like Mario
games are you lying to me I'm trying to
find new ones
oh I hope that all you're doing on the
Internet
yeah just kidding there's parental
controls you can't do anything else all
right so I see that you're wearing your
swimming trunks oh yeah
so what does that mean yes show me I
know I'm sorry we're supposed to go but
then we got so caught up with doing
jakey new stuff that the whole day just
went away but we get to go right now cuz
I only did a half day whoa and guess
what the ad geo and Tyco are gonna be
coming over and swimming with this too
Yeah right lowly yeah wait just with me
you're still love me you know and daddy
so I guess the energy of another kid
makes it less lonely right now with
interview and more people true all right
so I got my bathing suit on and it's
time to go swimming now and we're gonna
take the GoPro so you guys can join us
in the swimming fun and look at me with
my Lisp because I have my eyeliners in
kind of cool you can't see them on
camera I don't think but it's kind of
annoying that I could hear the list
cause like the air is coming out and
they like going through the trays and
then creating a list anyway let's go
swim Oh what happened I'm playing unfair
Mario unfair Mario what does that mean
it's super hard it's so rigged really
everywhere oh dang oh yeah that looks
pretty hard but you're ready to go son
yep let's do it yeah let's go get you in
your element
[Music]
[Applause]
it is almost 4:00 p.m. so that means the
Sun should be nice and safe for my baby
skin to tolerate look at that I love
walking through here because it looks
like you Europe so pretty
would you look at that
yes I'd be there at 4:30 okay do
see you in 30 minutes we do yeah
sometime I can't believe it's your last
day of summer and tomorrow you will be
an official 6th grader whenever I go in
a different grade for like the first day
I never feel like an actual 3rd grader
or 4th grader
similarly when do you start feeling it
like one week do it oh really
yeah what up whenever we actually
learned something ah great that's cool
that's gonna feel like I'm I'm so amazed
that you are gonna be in middle school
dude that's crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow new backpack okay such a cute little
backpack yeah hurry hurry let's go swim
vlogging I'm wearing my mask
oh honey we a dude we have to in order
for me to swim and I'll get tore up I
need to be wearing my mask and some gear
pull up because I like to do a lot of
spins underwater Oh and so if it's like
I need to use both my hands and not that
I had to like cover my nose and then
recently I keep getting water in my ears
yeah and it's been really painful so OH
Casey got us these earplugs I look cute
oh yeah he has these tuna so we got some
ear plugs oh yeah I have more sunscreen
if you need it look dude take us here
you finally get to have a little friend
he's like come on mom hurry up hey wait
a minute wait a minute
I gotta change
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah I remember when you were scared of
the water
you were terrified don't think I don't
again okay that's awesome
don't break that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Hey
[Music]
sandy yeah okay oh gee like dad I didn't
you know what I think
Sandhya o Sandhya who will s and yet
they was that same with yet job it's an
illness to Chinese go Cisco
beach either fish on this is stuff like
not right now mom let me play going on
they play on my cousin hey cutie you
slide right off
keeps couches are so slippery oh you're
so cute I like how he doesn't use the
pillow he uses you for a bellyful that's
true it I was like girl blocking you
totally just fell on you can it Vicki
[Music]
see that they take a are you saying
cutie
[Music]
[Music]